retailers expect about 18 percent that's
158 billion dollars of merchandise sold
during this holiday shopping season to
be returned wow this year many retailers
are making changes to their return
policy that could make it a little more
difficult and costly for consumers who
return stuff hello my name is Gail
Cherise Jones is USA today's national
business correspondent good morning to
you Sharice I swear I think they're
talking about me it says 60 percent of
retailers are changing their policy
because I will order two sizes okay and
then return one and I do that on a
regular basis right so they don't like
that no no yeah they're shrinking the
returns window and they're increasingly
making you pay to ship it back right or
a restocking fee used to be free returns
exactly but part of it is that so many
people did what you did yeah and they
would like order two or three of the
same size and different colors and they
would send back what they didn't want
and then they were having this mountain
of returns that they had to deal with
that exploded during the pandemic and
they just can't keep doing that it's too
expensive so they're giving you less
time to send it back and they're saying
if you do send it back it's going to
cost you well hold on make customers be
go ahead well I thought we in the stores
had a kind of understanding here they
don't have a big brick and mortar store
they're just going to have a you can
shop online right and therefore you do
buy two things because I'm not in the
store trying on all those that's the
convenience right they're breaking the
contract that's convenience but they
kind of want you to come to the store
you mean you try it on in person you
know that if it's the first time and
then you don't have to send it back and
they'll still take it back but you have
to put some money in the game you know
they're not going to just assume all of
the costs and you're saying these return
policies that that encourages people to
shop in person and be environmentally
conscious a little bit yeah I mean it's
not as much packaging if you're taking
it back you know they don't charge you
when you bring it to an actual store and
this way you're kind of more conscious
about what you're buying right you're
not just kind of stocking up on stuff
and then wasting it and sending it back
or that you'll be more selective about
because it really is going to change
what I do yes it is it's going to change
what I do and it's the main reason is
because it's costing them too much
that's it it's very expensive it's about
fifteen dollars per item when they have
to restock it and get the deodorant mark
off the shirt or stuff off the shoe put
it back on the sales floor a lot of
times it doesn't resell they have to
really discount it or it might be out of
season or out of style and so they lose
a lot of money doing that like 761
billion dollars worth of merchandise so
what is your suggestion what's your
suggestion Ms Jones well don't sit on
that gift if you're not sure you want it
you know look at their returns policy
because you might miss that window to
get an exchange or a refund or take it
back to the actual store you know return
it there you don't have to pay and you
know just think about what you want a
little bit more I mean like try it on
use AR on the website to see does that
lamp really look good in your living
room do you really want it and something
you're not as wasteful okay seriousness
somebody gives you a gift that you don't
like don't play around don't put it in
your closet to make them happy don't
appease them don't forget about it you
better look and make up your mind right
now okay all right you might save some
money that way but when they come back
to visit they're gonna be like
thank you very much